I want to introduce you to Jing Jing
gang a senior data scientist databricks
um
also at databricks staff software
engineer I'm not sure pronounce those
names correctly but good enough thank
you
so yeah so we're going to talk today
about scaling data workloads using the
best of the Both Worlds
good morning everyone my name is Chang
Yin Ang I'm a senior data scientist at
data breaks I help customers Implement
skillable and production ready ml
Solutions yeah I'm here staff software
engineer and databricks and then I'm the
top contributor in our participal so if
you have any question about that I'm
happy to answer later yeah so today I
would like to share with you from our
respective data science and also
software engineering backgrounds some
tips about how to scale your data
workloads you know whether it's
debugging your errors or and also it
comes down to debugging on performance
issues as well
so today there are two main topics
really and they tackle this two sets of
the same coin and the first site is
talking about how you can change almost
nothing in your pandas code and scale it
up to run on a distributed cluster the
second side of the same coin is now that
if you were to run on spark how do you
then add your own custom pandas API to
leverage that familiarity and then we'll
wrap up the talk by introducing to you a
new tool called spark connect that
allows you to University Park everywhere
more easily
this is an undeniable statement we use
this every day probably you know data
workloads and they are so widely
integrated and new best python libraries
you know matplotlibs cycling Etc but
really there's really one problem and
my computer science Professor used to
joke that if you have no questions to
ask at any classes or any talks just ask
this question and you instantly become
the smartest person in the room you know
so the problem is really about skill
ability right how do we skill using
pandas code
so of course the first easy thing to do
is to Simply throw a bigger and bigger
instance whether it's a CPU whether it's
a GPU and hopefully it just works but at
some point you will reach the point
where you are no longer satisfactory
with a performance and you hope to do
something better
so then the next naive thing to do is to
down sample data simply but I think a
lot of the data practitioners in the
room agree with me that data is so
precious why should I toss them away so
we don't want to do that so that leaves
us with no choice but to actually lead
to other distributed processing
framework and there are multiple of them
out there but today we'll cover spark
spark as you can see is open source for
since a very long time ago and there are
multiple language support as well
including SQL
and Scala and also R and today we'll
mainly focus on Pi spark right how do we
interface with spark using Python and so
you can see as the years go by since it
was open source the popularity of Pi
spark has also pretty much really much
increasing as well
so what is spark you know this is a
fundamental like distributed processing
engine and if you remember nothing from
this talk like about spark I just want
you to remember one thing you know it
has one driver and it can have multiple
number of worker nodes and this concept
of unsettable worker knows actually
really important because each worker
node can hold a subset of data which is
also commonly known as data partition
and so the driver would then be able to
distribute the workload across the
worker nodes and at a worker notes like
all of us we execute the tasks that were
given and then we report back to a
driver so that's a fundamental
architecture of spark a driver and a
multiple worker nodes
but of course we have to learn new
syntax nobody likes doing that and you
can see that at the very top right here
we have a pandas called snippet and then
you know this course number all it does
is to filter data where rows are more
have quantity that's more than 10 right
and then you see the question on the
down like the bottom here over here
there's pretty much no similarity we
have to learn how to view a spark
session and learn how to actually write
or select statements you no longer use
the Dot Lock or dot eye lock you know
impending anymore
but beyond just the surface level API
difference there is also fundamental
differences in how spark data frames and
panel data frames are implemented so
let's take a look so for spark data
frame it is not mutable so what that
means is that because spark data frames
are fundamentally built upon rdds which
stands for resilient distributed data
set once it is constructed it's no
longer being changed so it means that
when you add a new column or maybe when
you cast a column type differently What
spark does under the hood is to create
an entirely different different rdd
object
and of course it's distributed whereas
on for pandas data frame even if you
throw it a distributed cluster with huge
number of worker nodes pandas is only
going to run on the driver
because big spark data frames are
distributed there is no there's no set
of indexes nor row orders as well and
this is actually a topic that we'll dive
into a little bit more about when we
convert one into smart enough frame to
Pi smarter the data frame how do we
actually make them communicate to each
other
so the last property over here is
evaluation and this is probably one of
the most important properties that make
spark data frames fast so in spark data
frames there's a notion of lazy
evaluation it means that all spark
Transformations are actually not
executed unless you call the action
command so things like filter statements
your select statements those are all
lazy not eagerly evaluated until spark
has a chance to come up with optimized
logical plan behind the scene and then
you trigger an action which is maybe
something like account command and then
the execution would run
whereas pandas data frames evaluates
everything eagerly
so what if you don't want to learn spark
this is where Pi spark.pen does come in
some of you may have heard about the
koalas project before that we announced
in 2019 it has been officially
integrated into the Spy spark
environmental library in England 21 and
hence the name Pi spark.penders so what
this does is really unifying both
syntaxes from spark and into pandas so
you can see in this code snipper right
now I am just simply commenting out the
top line of import statement import
pandas as PD I replace it with import Pi
spark.penders SPS and you can see then I
am still using my Dot Lock pandas API in
my code I pretty much just change the
import from PD to PS and this works
which is great it means that now I no
longer need to learn a new syntax and
yet I can Leverage The distributed
processing power
so how does it work it seems like magic
which is great because then we you and I
actually don't really need to know about
that information detail but just to give
you a very high level to perhaps
Intrigue your appetite uh price product
pandas provides this lean API layer that
sits on top on spark and pandas so to
communicate between like Pi spark pandas
and also to spark data frame there is
something called an internal frame
that's basically acting as a
communication communication bridge
between the both so this internal frame
will hold all the metadata or the spark
data frames and it also holds the
mapping from the pi smarter panels data
frame to spark data frames as well so it
means that when we make changes to Pi
Sprout or pandas data frame the internal
frame will decide whether or not you
should create a new state or whether it
should copy a new state so that the
email evil property of Pi spark data
frames are still preserved
now many of you might be wondering about
the performance because it seems like
it's too good to be true uh that we we
don't need to actually change any syntax
so let's take a look at the distributed
free product over uh the cluster over
here first so you don't really need to
know the numbers uh even if you can't
read them so across each group we have a
different Benchmark task all the way
from calculating standard deviation to
join an accounting count but you can
notice that within each orange daughter
box you can see the downward lower Trend
you know so for each bar that you see
the blue orange and green goes from 464
notes to 256 nodes the takeaway is that
as we linearly increase this number of
nodes we see that the performance
actually almost linearly gets better as
well hence you see the downward Trend
Across The Benchmark task
and the good performance also exists in
single node cluster too so you can see
for the Blue Bar it represents pandas
and then for orange bar represents the
pandas API on spark which is why we
abbreviate as Viet spark.penders you can
also see the orange bar consistently
lower than the blue bars so it also
works very well on a single node cluster
compared to pandas
so why should you start maybe switching
to Pi spark.pandas or considering doing
it uh you can see the API coverage is
really increasingly like very steadily
across the years and we started from
koala 0.1 and now we're in pi spark 3.3
so there are three we divided the API
coverage by different groups in your
data frame series and indexes now we're
hovering right at around 70 to 80
percent and just on just that you know
this number is actually really good and
it will never really reach 100 because
some single node functions are you know
that are just don't make sense to be
converted to a distributed processing
method uh so you we don't expect 100
coverage
so what is the first president best
practices we're going to share so we
mentioned something about the indexes
you know the difference between pi spark
and pandas is in the pandas data frames
has indexes whereas Pi spark doesn't so
let's talk about the pi spark.penders
what are some indexes that we can
actually choose
so the first one is sequence
sequence means that you are implementing
the index that increases one by one and
this is actually the least performant
index choice because it forces all your
data to run on a single node because
your index needs to be increased you
know one by one that it needs to know
some order
so we should absolutely avoid this when
data is large
the second index which is distributed
sequence
means that we're still implementing the
index increase by one by one but it's
for each group
so it is better than sequence when data
is large
the third one though is the best
performing one for the index Choice it
means that we actually don't need the
index to be increasing one by one it can
maybe jump from one to three you know to
nine and so on and the index is indistic
so this helps because you don't no
longer need to force the order of the
rows to be always exactly the same
so it means that when you actually
convert your data frame to Pi
smart.penders the index choice is
actually something you need to pay close
attention to
now should you learn Pi spark or pi
spark.penders
have I convinced anyone to learn not
learn Pi spark yet or that's that's not
my task over here but it's really to
help you understand where when it's best
to use you know either uh so if you were
to know if you are really familiar
pandas already and you want to just
scale out your analysis and your task is
strictly restricted to only data
analysis then Pi Sparta pandas is a
really good choice
but we know that spark is more capable
than just doing data analysis it
actually also does data streaming as
well for example in graph processing so
if your use cases span outside data
analytics and include streaming and
include graph processing then you should
still learn Pi Spark
now let me turn it over to hugeon to
discuss once you have your spark code if
you were to know spark already how do
you then and your pandas function API on
top
thanks slinging
all right so we talked about the pandas
API on spark just now but um what if if
you want to uh like work together with
other libraries like you need to let's
say you need pandas native instance and
you want to work with psychic learning
then
we have some friends pandas friends in
price Park so um in case of the pandas
API on spark we compose Panda save API
on the top of the data frame but these
friends um it works together with pi
spark and then it handles the native
the pandas native instance
so there are two apis that supported in
pi spark the first one is pandas UDF and
then the second one is the pandas
function API
so the pandas UDF is actually an
expression you can think it's that it's
like column wise operation and then the
whereas pandas pandas function API is um
actually a query plan under the food so
you can think it's that like table wise
operation
UDF it works consistently with other
expressions and then scholar UDF or like
regular python UDF
and then you decorate it with pandas UDF
whereas pandas function API there are
some API defined under the data frame so
you invoke that to use that
here's the actual example
so the top one the pandas UDF you
decorate your function that deals with
for instance here
and then the second one uh it deal with
the the pandas data frame because it's
table wise operation
all right let's talk a little bit more
about the pandas UDF so the pandas UDF
uh it uh you have to you must annotate
um which type you want to take as an
input and output
so and then the pi spark will decide how
to execute by reading the type hints so
for instance um here I type the panda
Service as an input and output then the
pi spark will decide and then it will
transform and then it will perform a
scalar on operation
there are um serialized decentralized
and then executed in the vectorized
manner and then it will leverage the
numpy under the hood when actually it's
executed
so this is the three examples the first
one
um as I just mentioned uh since I
typed a panda series as an input and
output it transformed the values
and the second second one is the the
aggregation example so you take the
panda service and then it outputs the um
primitive type
so here I performed the sum so I perform
the aggregation
and the last one um in pi spark we have
nested types for instance struct type
the struct type is um converted to the
pandas data frame
so you can convert that pandas data
frame to the panda series
in case of pandas function API
of course you can optionally um annotate
the type but in matters which API you
invoke and then the pi spark will decide
how to execute them
based on which API you invoke
pandas UDF and functions functions API
they are all
um actually shared the same in-bane or
execution logic so they are both
serialized digitalized and executed in
vectorized manner too
so in the example below here I invoke
the map in pandas right but the pandas
UDF shares the same API but pandas
function API it depends on which API you
call
let's get let's take a look at the
example
so the first one um I group by and then
I apply in pandas right and then here
the each group will be a data frame
of a pandas data frame and then the the
subtract mean will be operated
in case of the second example I perform
the group by with Core Group and then it
will take the two data frame and then
each group of individual data frame we
convert it into the the function into
for instance here left and right
the last example is that the map in
pandas so this is similar with the rdds
map partitions so basically you're
applying the function in batch so this
iterator of pandas data frame will be
actually one partition under the hood
um this is an example of ml changing has
a better Insight than ml so she will
briefly explain the example
in ml is very common for us to have
this is our usual you specialize by
store or maybe buy a specific State and
Etc right so here we I want to revisit
the concept first like in really a
pandas function you can write whatever
you want right so this is an example of
me writing whatever I want it might
train my trigger function that literally
trains a random forest classifier model
and then it predicts the output and a
calculator model performance for each
device ID so this is an example of what
if I have many device IDs and many
devices you know I want to actually
predict maybe the rate of mechanical
failure and typically I maybe have two
choices one is to maybe Loop have
already a really long for Loop and just
look through each unique ID and then
train a different machine learning model
or maybe I could just duplicate my
notebook and then just pass in a
different sub sort of data frame every
single time right so but that is
actually very cumbersome so here you can
see that there's no spark code in here
it's really just really nice data frame
it returns that schema that has
basically three columns a device ID
number of training Samples used in model
training and lastly the model
performance in AOC metric
so I pass in this function to my group
by apply in pandas so you can see that
this removes the need of writing for
Loops or duplicating the code and this
works very well even in production too
so we have multiple multiple use cases
in across different industries that uses
this group by applying pandas to be able
to apply to the forecasting use cases
thanks
there is a common problem
when you um play with the pandas
functions API or UDF you might um see
some out of memory issue especially when
you on perform a group by and then apply
in pandas since one group is in the
memory the whole the group of the
um
pandas data frame will be in the memory
so you might face the out of memory and
then there is a common technique that is
basically salting but I mean that's
salting but basically you're adding the
one um column like hash column-ish and
then you separate separate into the
smaller group so so just to get let's
take a look at the the left table and
then here I added the salt column and
then in the second table
the group a has actually
um set up it into two because of the
salt
and then I can um operate the group by
again based on the the call
and then it will um show the final
result so basically it's two-phase group
right Group by
and how to do it in um chords
let's say the first example here I'm
grouping by um one column right and then
let's say the data is secured and then
the one group is like huge so it's all
in the memory then it might you know out
of memory
I convert that to code to the I added
the salt column in the second example so
I group by first and that will separate
the big group into you know multiple
groups and then that output I will Group
by again and then I aggregate it's like
sort of partial aggregate technique ish
so you can avoid out of memory by
salting
what about debug and um performance so
uh how to debug the the implementation
errors make sure it works on a single
node because the your function should
work in the single node
and then try to distribute it in Spock
and if you're using iterators like
mapping pandas
um make sure the use the python closers
or nested functions instead of one bit
one big function that is difficult to
debug or difficult difficult to profile
please make sure your functions are
optimized don't accessibly use for Loop
there are many um other techniques for
instance factorized vector by leveraging
the numpy so
um I I better don't use a lot of photos
make sure your data is properly
practitioned
um Pi spark itself um provide a loss of
partitioning apis for instance
repartition so make sure you have enough
partitions so it can be distributed and
then executed in parallel
use your spark UI to debug performance
issues you know add print and go to the
job Tab and Stage Tab and check the
standard on input and standard output
and errors
all right so we talked about the the
pandas friends in um Pi spark this sort
of um additional section the spark
connect the in current price spark
development the spark Community is
putting effort to implement the spa
connect and this is also closely related
to the the pandas UDF and the pandas
function API
I will start with the general problem
that Spock has
so the
is often associated with the data center
itself so in the cluster
um your spark driver will in the will in
your um spark cluster together so your
application logic Works in within your
spark cluster it's not your laptop
so if you zoom in the spark driver which
is basically um you can think it's that
it's spark client
the spark driver the client although is
client driver it does lots of things
it has your application logic and then
it has a catalyst or twister and it
dispatch your task into the the cluster
and it has a little bit of um
distributed execution Logic for instance
code generation
so it's pretty heavy and it's um there
are all like very coupled together each
other
and then the problem is that instead
don't um applications
um don't do not match with the current
spark structure for instance um you want
to do the inter like debug and then
develop in the interactive shell or IDE
you're this heavy One Big Driver should
like
um together within your laptop for
instance
and then the other language supports are
difficult yes there are other some
language support existent now but they
all are very un implemented in a very
complicated manner because you have to
implement the jbm access logic by
yourself so and then active devices like
Raspberry Pi or like in your browser or
your iPad this this big spark driver
cannot work in those devices
so how do we um deal with this problem
right now
for the modern applications we just send
the SQL string or jdbc the Apex box
support the diff server that supports
like jdbc or odbc
so it takes the SQL string or jdbc
request and then it and it excuse it
does address those requests
for um Jupiter or IDE there are some
existing solutions for instance Apache
Libby but under the hood they send the
quotes in string to the server and then
you get the output so you cannot really
at a break and then um debug
and the other language support as I just
mentioned they're um implemented in a
very complicated manner
spark connect itself um resolved that
problem by decoupling the API layer
layer to the front so it will create a
um sort of portable message and then it
will ask the
subscriber to execute the job so the
applications
um is very thin because what it does is
that just it construct the message and
then ask ask the spark driver to execute
the job
so it can address ID or other language
support very easily
let's take a look at the implementation
detail quickly so the data frame API
Scala or Java or python they all share
the SQL module under the hood and then
the SQL module is actually consisting of
the logic logical plan and that this
logical plan is optimized or with the
loss of techniques for instance
predicate push down or column Printing
and then it will be executed
spark connect client will construct this
logical plan before the optimization
which is unresolved logical plan
and then it will just send to the spark
driver server and then the spark driver
would execute those job and then it will
send the result back to the spark remote
client site in Arrow format
so by doing that you can Leverage The
Power of Apache spark everywhere as I
just mentioned you can use it in the you
know IDE like Jupiter very easily I will
show you a bit of example later and then
since the it just construct the message
right so other other language can
implement this um client layer very
easily
and of course
we um we now in spark 3.4 we edit the
SQL support in Python and then in the
master branch in the next spark version
we'll have the full support of pandas
apn's pop in the python UDF structure
streaming ml and then they will be all
available in the next part version
all right so this is the the simple
example I just want to um show you just
the simple idea like how it works so I
just run the jupyter
um server in my laptop locally and then
what I need to do is just I just pip in
slow Pi spot and then I can just ship
the existing logic right away and then I
can easily walk together with
interesting bi tool
this is just
um just simply just show the idea I
don't I didn't have to set up like
Apache Libby or Jupiter Enterprise I
just PP install and that's it
this is the another example
um of spark connect so I'm using
um IDE with separating the computation
to the cluster so here I can see the DF
data frame and then the result based on
the result I can execute other jobs I
can see the schema here or I can perform
other operations like for instance count
to see how many data is inside
the result is a bit slow now
but it will show
yeah
so you can run the job very easily with
IDE
and then interactively debug
you can um run everywhere within your
browser or Raspberry Pi
it's very light so it can even walk in
you know like node.j notes or like
browser anywhere and then it will show
the the you know pretty chart like this
very easily
without doing the computation of all the
optimization or
scheduling the task
within your browser
right that's what we um prepared so far
if you have any questions I'm happy to
answer
thank you
hi great talk I'm super excited I had a
quick question because a lot of the
times when I'm putting together
forecasts I don't have just one
dimensional variable that I'm gripping
by so you know instead of just being
items I might be looking at an item a
customer and a DC combination and
obviously there's like a a specific
order that I would want to separate
those out in so how does spark handle
that especially in the ml context yeah
so if you were to have multiple groups
model columns you need to goodbye that
it means you will just pass in more
columns in a goodbye
so you're specifying the group by in
like your pandas
function or like the pi spark pandas
function because I didn't see you
specify a dimensional columns in that
example so that's why I was curious yeah
so in this case when we have multiple
columns we actually don't need to change
anything in this pandas code right here
because this assumes that we are running
this code on each group already you know
so and then on this in this example we
apply this function on a group instance
right so spark DF dot group I is a group
instance and then we assume that this
group instance will capture all your
groups so if you were to have more than
one group then you would add an
additional column within this group by
statement and then the train my model
would still apply on that particular
like basically set of groups that you
have supplied gotcha perfect thank you
uh thank you I I have a question about
pandas UDF and python UDF
so what's the difference between these
two because
in theory in Python UDF you can also use
pandas right so it was a difference
between these two yes so we are going to
share the same called Park soon
yeah so yeah what you said is all
correct yeah yeah we'll share the same
code path under the hood in the next
spot version
meaning that yeah what you said is
correct yeah it shares it's the same
currently is separate called path
because pandas UDF came out later
so it's vectorized authorization but
operate it leverage the vectorized
operation operation
but yes I'll be uh working on looking to
making the sharing this input path yeah
so it means that python udfs are
executing the code row at a time
but pandas UDF has another name which is
vectorized UDF and that means that you
can execute a function batches at a time
so in spark the default settings you can
actually set the maximum records per
batch that you can process each time I
believe the default number is 10 000 so
if you were to use pandas UDF or
vectorize UDF compared to using UDF you
should see a performance boost because
of that Max records per batch setting
thank you that makes sense that have a
follow-up question about that for pan as
udif do you use the pi spark pandas API
under the hood which means it will be
infinitely scalable or you use the
normal Canon panels
implementation in memory implementation
so you mean in the context of
AI whether or not we are using and US
API
converting to price
yeah it is using pandas API yes sorry
last question
so for this Pi smart pandas their frame
is there any concept concept of ordering
I see indices but no ordering right uh
we we have it is not by default but we
have an option to support the ordering
so it will it will have to sort by
default but uh it is because that Pi
spark itself doesn't guarantee the order
so we need to manually sort but it's
disabled by default and then supported
by an option right yeah
okay we have time for two questions
oh thank you
yeah I was just wondering
um what is preventing you guys from just
implementing salting under the hood
automatically
um
you want honest sensor
yeah I mean like it's basically like
partial aggregation
um technique so not all aggregation
functions actually can leverage this
technique for instance
um like for instance count for some you
can just do the partial aggregation but
let's say
yeah median or those things cannot be um
so like that so actually if you're
walking on um like
um streaming you know manner execution
instead of this
um salting technique
I'm curious to know what's in the
15 to 20 percent like do you support
multi-indexes on columns and rows all
the time series things that are in
pandas
yeah so I assume you are talking about
the API coverage right yep yeah so there
is actually a pretty detailed
documentation link uh that let me see
whether I can just
click on it right now
so a lot of things are things like yeah
sorting the in time index uh so you can
see that for each on this page over here
there are multiple sort of different
types of API then you can check whether
one is implemented or not and then there
is also something that has like a p over
here that what is implemented but what
are some some parameters that are
missing so if you are curious you know
what are not supported then this would
be your documentation to refer to
but you will you generally notice the
trend of a lot of the time Delta indexes
that are not supported and then there
are also some things more about like
doing some count for like median it just
doesn't make sense because we like for
example when we keep going back to the
As Above median is because you really
didn't do need every single row to be
sorted to find the median and if you
want to speed that up in a spark data
frame that's just no way right that's
why in spark you can only do approximate
median
okay
thank you again the speakers
so thank you all for coming up thank you
thank you